you
um I just wonder if you would take me
back to your reflections of that night
and the weeks and the days that followed
I was 11 when that happened and it was
one of the very first time that a news
story really affected me because I had
fear fear for my dad who had dreadlocks
my brother who was of dark skin
um but what about your reflections yeah
while I was part of the black Police
Association and
um even though I was based in North
London at the time there was definitely
a sense of dread
on you know you could relate to the
Lawrence Family and Stephen could have
been my brother my cousin Etc so it it
it had that real sort of relevance and
hurt and pain and it's that this case
has always been a touchstone for the
black community
um you know I'm very privileged
especially since giving evidence that
McPherson inquiring to the death of
Stephen
and I was one of the officers who said
that the the Met was institutely racist
um we we got to know the Lawrence Family
and um you know it's great to
um have that sort of conversation with
uh Neville and Doreen because they gave
their Humanity uh such dignity
um and they would Challenge and they
wouldn't be gaslighted and said
everything's fine they always stood the
their um their Corner stood in their
corn very strong and it gave us a real
sense of how to put ourselves across in
the black Police Association and to not
um
acquiesce but to say it as it is and
because we're part of the black
community and we speak up on behalf of
the black community and in particular
the lawrencies and what they were going
through so it had so many
um overlaps uh with me personally I
think also you know I'm a Jamaican
Heritage similar to uh the Lawrence
Family and so I can relate to them in
that respect as well what did you make
of the lawrences I'd say dignified fight
for justice and and I said to you while
we were watching Sherman's report there
actually you don't hear from Neville
very much but what were your early
indications of their their fight for
justice
well their grit and determination that
they needed to know what had happened to
their son
um obviously they know he was killed uh
by uh races in the community but why
weren't they arrested because there was
a lot of information at the time
um how why wasn't this acted upon and
obviously they'd start to find out that
there was a collusion with the family
there was corruption
incompetence and to some extent and of
course they realized that there was a
racial element to it and um and then
they start to look wider and and see
that this wasn't just a one-off you know
the way in which uh Stephen murder was
investigated and and as a result of that
they sensed that there was a wider issue
of institutional racism that needed to
be addressed and I think that's why
um Nelson Mandela when he came over he
totally identified with the case and as
a result of that he spoke up on their
behalf which really resonated with the
labor party and then because this was
the sort of mid-90s and obviously the
election in 97 they were voted in and
the labor party totally accepted that
there was issues to deal with policing
in a way that had to be addressed and it
couldn't be left
um ongoing and kicked into the long
grass had to be dealt with and and I was
really pleased when the Home Secretary
Jack straw announced the um McPherson
inquiry and it was a statutory inquiry
so it wasn't just another reporter
review but it had teeth and it could
hold the police to account because I
truly believe there's nothing wrong with
them I can't be addressed by what's good
in it it just needs the right leadership
it needs the right political will to
hold them to account to make it the the
Police Service more accountable and
transparent and it's very similar to
police forces across the country and and
it just really needed that sort of
political will and independent oversight
of not only the report but the
recommendations and how they were going
to be rolled out because what gets
measured gets done and that was the
important thing about those
recommendations because they made and
that there were Watershed in terms of
policing and changing policing for for
the better so you fed into that 1999
McPherson report talk to me about the
the cultural changes that happened
within the Met police in that 10-year
period
well immediately the Casual racism the
n-word the P were the W word stopped
right so they realized you know that the
bad cops knew there to shape up and and
it created a positive atmosphere so the
good cops would call out the bad cops
their diversity inclusion
um was you know the
golden thread going through so many
different forms of
um policing issues it had operational
effectiveness and
um I was able to uh show how uh
complaints within the organization
reducing complaints by the community was
reducing policing policing was was a
light touch it wasn't a heavy-handing
people felt uh the police were for them
instead of feeling overpoliced and
underprotected
um so and it's because the independent
oversight was there holding the police
to account through the Stephen Lawrence
Steering group chaired by Jack straw at
Neville and Dorian Lawrence in that
group and I was one of the um people as
chair of the national black Police
Association to be privileged to be on
that group but I was also in the room
when Paul Condon uh said these are
recommendations we've been called
institutional racism we will use it as
an aspiration to be better
not to go into some Antics or Gaslight
but to say listen we can be the Police
Service that the public demand so it's
really interesting to get your thoughts
then finally Mr Logan and where you see
the metropolitan police at the moment
we've had recent report that said it's
institutionally homophobic xenophobic
racist
is the right man in charge to push the
Met into the place where it needs to be
well I know Mark Rowley was in the met
when um leading up to Crusader dick
taking up a commission ship it sadly it
reminds me the look and feel of policing
reminds me of a primacation era it seems
to be more of an occupying Force as you
say the case you report showed not only
um that the
certain units like the Parliamentary and
diplomatic protection group or is that
safe haven Predators you know
Carrick and cousins all of these people
which you think never would happen if
there wasn't the checks and balances if
supervisors uh were doing the job they
weren't being protected there wasn't
that culture of fear that prevented the
good cops calling out the bad cops and
those systemic failures were being dealt
with in a way that you started to see
um real significant change and of course
the political Will's not there
um to hold the commission and the chief
constables account and that's why the
commissioner can say oh well I don't
believe I'm an Institutional racism so
that that until you acknowledge you have
a problem you've got to do something
about it so I don't think Mark Rowley is
really equipped to deal with it because
he was there when he was going bad yeah
I I you know when they come through that
culture they're very protective you know
they don't keep that critical distance
and they're not able to really do the
sustainable change that's going to hold
that Police Service that met and the
rest of the police services around the
country to the level of um integrity and
ethics and professional behavior and of
course getting the basics right that's
why the Mets in special measures because
they're not even just getting the basics
right around how to police London okay
Mr Leroy Logan pleasure to have you in
the studio today thank you for your
thoughts